[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrada
[Música]
bienvenidos a en primera plana de rci
france24 esta semana con un programa muy
especial verán sin duda este 2020 que ya
vamos acabando ha estado marcado por una
palabra coronavirus hoy vamos a dedicar
en primera plana a reflexionar más allá
de la sanidad la economía o la política
como la pandemia ha cambiado quiénes
somos qué efectos deja lakovic en
nuestra forma de ver el mundo y de
relacionarnos les presenta nuestras
invitadas
karen buj es periodista independiente
bienvenida gracias carlos thalía olvera
politólogo y lingüista especialista en
innovación en medios de comunicación
thalía bienvenida gracias carlos y en
dúplex desde madrid la filósofa de la
universidad complutense ana carrasco con
de anna buenos días hola buenos días y
encantada de estar con vosotros hoy 2020
el año que cambió nuestras vidas hoy en
primera plana
[Música]
el segundo confinamiento que vive
francia está teniendo fuertes efectos
psicológicos sobre la población según
recientes cifras uno de cada cinco
franceses sufre de algún estado
depresivo dos veces más de lo que se
registraba hace tan solo un mes a las
dificultades económicas y al desempleo
temporal se añade la soledad y el
aislamiento hoy en primera plana
hablamos de cosas como la fatiga
emocional pero también de si la comida
nos ha podido ayudar en algunas facetas
personales a reencontrarnos con nosotros
mismos en cualquier caso lo que parece
claro es que asumiendo lo positivo y lo
negativo que la situación pueda tener
este 2020 será el año que cambió
nuestras vidas repasemos algunas
portadas antes de preguntar a mis
invitadas diario le parisien estudiantes
año negro sin profesores ni dinero ni
empleo lacko a tener 20 años en 2020
como esta crisis influye en la juventud
semanario loves se hace eco de otro
fenómeno consecuencia de todo lo vivido
en este 2020 viva la bici revolución
como esta crisis ha hecho disparar en
algunos países la conciencia ecológica
de economy se pregunta
portada cómo sobrevivir a la próxima
catástrofe si hemos aprendido lecciones
durante la pandemia bueno les pregunto a
las 3 2020 va a marcar un antes y un
después en todas nuestras vidas de
alguna forma tienen esa sensación
karen así es carlos sin duda este 2020
es lo que muchas películas ciencia
ficción vaticinaba en un futuro
distópico donde la distancia social las
mascarillas la falta de libertades
serían estas películas y parece que como
un sueño podemos hacer un chasquido y
desaparece pero no ha sido así y esto es
nuestra nueva realidad y hay que
adaptarnos a ella y hemos visto cómo
este 2020 hemos estado expuestos a
mascarillas a un aislamiento durante
meses confinados que nos han alejado de
la vida normal de las personas hemos
estado expuestos también a la falta de
contacto táctil con las personas y a un
miedo que los medios de comunicación
también nos han introducido y todo esto
pues tiene una serie de resultados que
bueno vamos a ir viendo carlos pero si
este año es un anti un después como
sociedad y como personas
thalía
por supuesto que fue y que es todavía un
año fuera de lo ordinario cuyas
consecuencias no se van a acabar como
todos quisiéramos cuando pasemos al 2021
pero por alguna razón no siento que haya
realmente como un antes y un después las
situaciones que observamos en este año
ya existían antes de la de la pandemia y
lo que vino a ser la crisis económica y
la crisis económica de cristian y tarja
fue exacerbar las o por lo menos
hacerlas visibles desde mi punto de
vista
para carrasco con madrid bueno yo tengo
varias cosas que decir al respecto no
estaría de acuerdo tanto con thalía como
con karen y efectivamente creo que el
comité ha supuesto una especie de efecto
contraste que ha puesto de relieve
muchos problemas estructurales que
habían allí desde el punto de vista de
la injusticia no social por el punto de
vista del hecho
sostienen insostenibilidad por el punto
de vista también personal de como muchas
veces somos una sociedad que nos ha
educado la de tal manera que no estamos
preparados para
no estamos preparados para conseguir de
alguna forma lidiar con situaciones que
se salgan fuera de lo que pensamos
o lo que es lo que esperamos y en este
sentido creo que aunque es verdad que el
covite ha supuesto la cob y está
supuesto este efecto contraste yo sí
creo que va a haber y que hay de hecho
un cambio radical y lo podríamos
estructurar en tres partes desde el
punto de vista del ámbito privado que
estamos hablando precisamente de un
cambio a nivel de como hablabas de
fatiga emocional pero también de cómo
nos hemos enfrentado a nosotros mismos
cómo nos hemos enfrentado también a
nuevas formas de relacionarnos con los
demás con la pérdida de contacto pero lo
que me parece más inquietante y esto es
una cosa que me gustaría recalcar es que
si ahí va a perón antes y un después'
está sobre todo circunscrito algo que ha
pasado aquí ha sido la injerencia de lo
público y lo privado a qué me refiero de
repente el ámbito del trabajo ha
introducido en muchas en muchas casas
por ejemplo el ámbito de que los demás
estoy estoy en mi casa esto es muy raro
vosotros no debéis estar viendo mi casa
así que de alguna manera vosotros y todo
el mundo que está en este programa está
dentro de mi casa se han borrado esos
límites de lo público y lo privado se ha
eliminado también elementos de intimidad
de forma que es verdad había elementos
que ya estaban ahí por ejemplo las redes
sociales o exponerse a través de
diferentes canales pero de repente lo
que hemos encontrado es que esa
difuminación es total y de alguna manera
y esto me parece muy relevante decía
antes que tenía que ver como un
aprendizaje de cómo no sabemos perder
no sabemos afrontar la adversidad y qué
es lo que hemos hecho o que lo que se ha
hecho en muchos casos pues intentar
entretenerse
estábamos esperando que esto acabara y
la cuestión es que quizá no se trate de
que esto acabe quizás no se trata de
estar cruzando los dedos para esperar
que todo que de repente despertemos en
el 2021 de forma distinta sino saber
adaptarnos a esto y creo que el cambio
del 20 este antes el coronavirus aún
después de coronavirus sea un ac/dc
tiene que ver también con cómo de pronto
nos hemos dado cuenta o muchas veces
quizá ya ni siquiera nos hemos dado
cuenta de que hay
la manipulación de una inoculación de
ciertos elementos que nos han vaciado de
subjetividad nos han vaciado de nosotros
mismos nos han vaciado de un pensamiento
propio y el que continuamente lo que
estamos viendo es una fagocitación de
mensajes que que no te no cuestionamos
por qué tenemos miedo
voy a vamos a hablar de eso precisamente
ana y os pregunto somos conscientes de
que quizá la gran transformación es que
hemos pasamos una buena parte de nuestro
día digiriendo y hablando y comentando
informaciones ligadas al coronavirus en
un porcentaje bestial es decir toda
nuestra vida ahora mismo gira en torno a
lo mismo al mismo núcleo informativo
karen así ha sido todos los medios de
comunicación si miramos todas las redes
sociales incluso incluso no saben
alertas de coronavirus cuando estamos
viendo cualquier vídeo en youtube esto
es la tónica de hoy en día toda la
información gira en torno a la pandemia
al kobe a las medidas a los protocolos y
esto tiene y esto tiene un efecto en
nosotros como personas
así que nuestra salud mental porque
están expuestos constantemente a este
tipo de informaciones crea una serie de
ansiedad y esto tiene unos efectos que
repercute directamente en nuestra salud
mental que eso también se traduce en
como nosotros estamos a nivel físico
incluso y esto y está esta ansiedad no
hay que no hay que dejarla de lado
porque la ansiedad es principio de una
depresión y ya la organización mundial
de la salud
alertada en 2019 que había que tener
cuidado había que exponer especialmente
atención a la depresión porque supone la
primera causa de discapacidad en el
mundo y sin duda el cob y la cob ya ha
disparado los números en este año de la
depresión y de estas situaciones de
inestabilidad emocional porque también
las personas se han visto expuestas
ahora y aun isla aislamiento ha
aumentado también la la violencia de
género por estar encerrados en los
hogares y una serie de disparidades por
por tema también de falta de dinero
falta económica los divorcios han
aumentado en todo el mundo
de hecho japón sacó una estrategia para
intentar que no haya tantos divorcios
que invitaban a las parejas de convivir
y de pagar un precio por noche y con
asesoría de un abogado gratis para que
evaluaran bien sí sí sí esto esto era
necesario el divorcio no hizo una serie
de cosas que hemos ido viendo que no han
afectado que han hecho que nuestra
estabilidad emocional y quiénes somos
incluso nuestra identidad no esté muy
claro porque la mascarilla también ha
quitado y no sabes personificado tal día
somos conscientes de que la pandemia lo
ha impregnado absolutamente todo todas
las facetas de nuestra vida y que quizá
nunca hayamos vivido nada algo parecido
antes es cierto que la información
relativa a la pandemia ocupó y sigue
ocupando un espacio mediático muy
importante la prueba de que estamos
hablando
y bueno lo que caracteriza a las
sociedades actualmente es la exposición
permanente a la información y solamente
que si quisiera como que no nos quedemos
solamente en un diálogo entre citadinos
digamos tenemos que ser conscientes de
que 40% un poco más de 40% la población
del mundo no tiene acceso a internet
entonces estas personas no están
bombardeadas digamos por esta
información que viene de las redes
sociales además de todos los otros
medios después porque sentimos que
permea toda todos los aspectos de
nuestra vida
hay muchas cosas que tienen que ver con
la pandemia primero hubo que informar a
la población sobre las medidas de
prevención de la enfermedad y la
gravedad también hubo muchos debates
sigue habiendo muchos debates sobre la
respuesta de los gobiernos ante la
situación y para saber si en tal país
había sido
había dado buenos resultados o no por
otra parte hubo mucha información
también sobre lo que la sobre la forma
en la que la población está viviendo la
pandemia y bueno ya lo decían antes las
consecuencias sociales políticas
económicas en lo personal y hasta en lo
psicológico y finalmente se tuvo que
hacer frente a otro problema que fue la
desinformación y las noticias falsas y
eso ocupó un espacio bastante grande en
la en los medios de comunicación y sólo
por para responder a tu pregunta el tema
de las pandemias no es tan nuevo ya
tenemos en la en la época reciente
tenemos varias pandemias hice una
pequeña lista rápida es dar por ejemplo
el 96 en reino unido estuvo la
enfermedad que se llamó de las 'vacas
locas' entre 2002 y 2004 el sars y en
china hay algunos países asiáticos desde
el 2005 las diferentes epidemias de
chikungunya en muchos países 2009-2010
la pandemia de influenza virus h1
n 1 que inició en méxico en 2012 el
'maersk off principalmente en arabia
saudita y el medio oriente y en 2003
entre 2013 y 2015 el ébola en áfrica
occidental
entonces ya vivimos en un mundo en donde
hay han habido este tipo de fenómenos a
veces lo que pasa es que somos muy poco
conscientes de ello en unos instantes
debería dar la palabra a anna desde
madrid les quiero preguntar también si
hay motivos positivos que pueden
hacernos combatir la fatiga emocional de
la que estamos hablando que nos haya
dado este 2020 pero va a ser la vuelta
de esta breve pausa hasta ahora
[Música]
a
españa es el país del mundo con más
artistas condenados a penas de prisión
por lo que dicen en sus obras
concretamente 14 esto es lo que revela
el informe sobre el estado actual de la
libertad artística en el mundo y que
hace referencia a datos de 2019 pero que
en el caso de españa cuenta con casos
que fueron muy sonados también en 2018
como particularmente el del rapero by
tonic que en 2018 fue condenado a tres
años y medio de prisión por
enaltecimiento del terrorismo injurias
contra la corona y amenazas y cabe
destacar que val tonic era prácticamente
desconocido antes de su primera
detención fue en ese momento cuando
estalló su popularidad que creció más
aún cuando justo antes de entrar en
prisión
el rapero decidió exiliarse a bélgica
donde continúa todavía a día de hoy
pendiente de si la justicia belga decide
extraditarlo o no tal y como pide la
justicia española
[Música]
después de españa irán es el país con
mayor número de artistas encarcelados
según la organización no gubernamental
free bus que habla que 11 escritores
activistas y también director de cine en
este caso
mohammad rasoulof fueron condenados en
el último año en el último caso el
director de cine por hacer propaganda
contra el estado es muy interesante
porque antes de recibir el llamado a
pagar su condenar a su luz había logrado
sacar clandestinamente del país su
última producción de disney vilo no hay
que ganó el máximo galardón en el
festival de cine de berlín para más allá
de los números de personas que van a la
cárcel en la presión que sufren los
artistas los cineastas por ejemplo
tienen que mandar su guión y su
producción final para recibir una
aprobación para ser mostrada en los
cines lo que ha llevado a que muchos en
el pasado dejen de trabajar en el país
pero la mayor presión está en las
mujeres cantantes que tienen prohibido
cantar en solitario desde la revolución
islámica en 1979
[Música]
con nueve entre rejas turquía está entre
los países del mundo que más artistas
tienen ahora mismo encarcelados por
haber hecho durante su carrera arte
muchos son muchos de ellos son kurdos y
son representados después del golpe de
estado 2016 por ejemplo uno de los
últimos entrar a la cárcel fue el
director de una obra de teatro kurda que
quería representarse en estambul en
kurdo el director fue detenido durante
unas horas luego después fue liberado
pero el caso más paradigmático de lo que
es el artista en turquía es el del
rapero es el el más famoso de turquía
2018 fue encarcelado por promover las
drogas y estuvo en cárcel durante un año
en prisión preventiva después sin ningún
tipo de prueba fue el liberado y ahora
vive en alemania
porque la historia se escribe día a día
porque la actualidad no espera la
información dondequiera que esté en
cualquier circunstancia todos los temas
para entender el mundo
para imaginar el mundo
france24 una mirada diferente liberté
égalité actually team
seguimos aquí en primera plana de
recibir france24 esta semana hablando de
como el 2020 fue el año o es el año que
va a cambiar nuestras vidas antes de
irme debemos la pausa decía que quería
hablar con ana carrasco con de nuestra
filósofa desde la universidad
complutense de madrid
anna somos conscientes que la pandemia
es lo que estamos comentando lo
impregnado absolutamente todo y que
nunca hemos vivido quizás algo así
dentro de la sociedad de las redes y de
la inmediatez es decir tener tantos
impactos a diario sobre un mismo núcleo
temático
bueno creo que sí es verdad que ha
habido una en nuestra época ciertamente
ha habido otras otras pandemias y aquí
en este en este punto no voy a hacer un
poco de aparición de profesar
universitaria hay un hay un un libro de
filosofía que se llama el leviatán de
hobbes y es muy conocido por la portada
en la portada aparece una figura del
leviatán que es un soberano que está
compuesto por muchas personas y hay una
cosa que no se suele ver y es que ese
soberano está rodeando una ciudad y en
esa en esa ciudad sobre los muros
aparecen pequeñas figuritas que llevan
como un pico y ese pico son mascarillas
médicas de la época lo interesante es
que el leviatán de hobbes se da cuenta
de cómo a través de una pandemia a
través de miedo ha habido una hay una
serie de transformaciones políticas en
los que aparece un estado totalitario
porque empiezo de esta forma a la manera
de a la hora de abordar la respuesta a
la pregunta porque creo que es verdad
que hay una exposición masiva pero lo
importante algo interesante que me
parece a mí es que esta exposición
masiva
velando otra cosa porque ya no es tanto
lo que hablamos o lo que escuchamos sino
lo que estamos haciendo y lo que no nos
estamos dando cuenta hay una conciencia
de que estamos muy preocupados por la
pandemia estamos preocupados por la cob
y te estamos muy preocupados por aquello
que nos pasa a nosotros a nuestros
familiares a la sociedad pero no nos
estamos dando cuenta de todas las
modificaciones que estamos
experimentando y antes podíamos hablar
decía decía decía karen que había una
especie de sensación de apocalyptica
pero que la relación de apocalyptica
implica que hay una aparición de una
cierta distopía nos hemos que hemos
intentado salir de esta situación
recurriendo a soluciones que son
distópicas de eliminación de libertades
hemos puesto por ejemplo en libertad a
seguridad y lo hemos dado como algo
normal como algo como algo común y no
hemos nos hemos detenido a pensar en los
cambios estructurales a nivel social ya
nivel político que se están
experimentando y éste ha coincidido en
un momento que es verdad que ha habido
otras pandemias es verdad que medida
hasta el leviatán de hobbes pero es
verdad que en el año que vivimos en el
2020 han confluido una zona bastante
peligrosa varios varios elementos uno es
el problema de la crisis de la verdad de
las de las de las facebook crisis de la
verdad en un momento en el que se asocia
que la verdad o tiene que ver con los
hechos o que es una verdad subjetiva de
tal manera que todo el mundo tiene su
verdad porque hemos perdido la noción de
lo que es verdad y lo que es mentira y
esto es algo que se estaba lastrando
tremendo verdad
carlos que es algo tremendo perder esa
noción no que aparte da mucho terreno de
especulación para los movimientos
complotistas y que lo estamos viendo
estos días claro y eso sé que es uno eso
sé que es un elemento nuevo cuestionar a
la ciencia es decir los datos
científicos no se pueden cuestionar
podemos opinar sobre otras cuestiones
pero cuestionar a la ciencia y eso lo
estamos viendo pero pero ten en cuenta
carlos que incluso la propia ciencia
tiene un concepto de verdad que nosotros
relacionados con esa objetividad de los
datos no estamos entendiendo la verdad
de la ciencia siempre un proceso es
relacional son y no tiene que ver con lo
subjetivo tiene que ver con cómo se
relaciona en un proceso de conocimiento
y eso tiene que ver con investigación
tiene que ver con un trabajo no es decir
esta es mi verdad y de repente lo que
encontramos y este es el segundo
elemento clave tenemos los medios de
comunicación y las redes sociales en los
que haya más un efecto un efecto burbuja
con el algoritmo entonces pensamos que
ese complot está relacionado
precisamente con aquello que realmente
pasa y muy bien y estoy de acuerdo con
lo que decía tal ya no hay un porcentaje
de la población que no está
experimentando ese bombardeo que
nosotros como como parte del primer
mundo estamos estamos sufriendo no pero
claro eso nos invisibiliza a esas
transformaciones que se van a quedar ahí
no y es lo que me parece peligroso vamos
a vivir con asia venga
cerramos ya porque si no tenemos que
hacer intervenciones un pelín más cortas
anna venga
venga luego retomamos porque hay muchos
temas más que os quiero plantear por
ejemplo los lazos sociales surgidos a
raíz de la pandemia ustedes creen que
saldremos de esta pandemia con un tejido
social más reforzado y no necesariamente
decir ser más individualista o mirar más
por el colectivo son tendencias que aún
es demasiado pronto para verlas thalía
si este antes de hablar
exactamente sobre el lazo social
quisiera detenerme un poco en una de las
medidas que se tomaron para prevenir los
contagios que se llamó de
distanciamiento social y que creo que
tuvo un impacto bastante fuerte
precisamente en lo psicológico porque en
realidad lo que se pedía no era un
distanciamiento social sino un
distanciamiento físico y en ese cambio
de adjetivos digamos creo que hay
y esto permite digamos a la gente de
percibir la distancia de una forma
realmente diferente y después sobre él
sobre los lazos pues bueno creo que se
ha creado también todo un discurso
alrededor del mundo después de la
pandemia no que en el que va a haber más
solidaridad entre las personas que vamos
a tener mayor conciencia de nuestra
huella ecológica que vamos a consumir de
forma responsable que vamos a consumir
principalmente productos locales pero
eso contrasta con la realidad de repente
me puse a pensar en como un ejemplo
digamos emblemático y pienso en esta
posición que está viendo actualmente
entre pequeños y medianos comerciantes y
el gigante de las ventas en línea amazon
que este año aumentó sus ganancias en un
porcentaje extremadamente alto no
entonces tal vez es una forma parte de
la esperanza que queremos todos no
solamente de que la situación 6
digamos que resolvamos la situación sino
que cambiemos lo que salgamos renovados
de esta situación de hecho la
organización mundial de la salud y ha
dicho que el coronavirus no va a ser una
excepción y que entramos en una era en
la que va a haber más pandemias karen
esto cambia nuestra forma de vivir de
ser de estar en el mundo este es ha sido
la primera prueba de algo que ha venido
para quedarse y que todavía no somos
conscientes de ello que aquella
normalidad para que siempre nombramos ya
nunca volverá a ser la misma parece que
lo que dicen los expertos es que no que
nuestra nueva normalidad o la normalidad
es esta que estamos viviendo hay muchos
optimistas que piensan que después de
algunos meses del 2021 después
volveremos como estábamos antes pero la
realidad es que hemos tomado una serie
de medidas que hemos ido adaptando a lo
largo de este año como puede ser a
simple vista lo más básico ya solo la
forma de llevar la higiene de diario
lavarse todos los días las manos
constantemente utilizar el gel
desinfectante
todos estos pequeños detalles son
incorporar nuestra realidad y también a
las empresas se le exige también el
personal les exige que tengan
responsabilidad también con los
empleados en tomar una serie de medidas
sanitarias para la propagación de virus
y demás entonces en esta tesitura no
parece que la normalidad que conocíamos
antes parezca llegar de hecho se han
producido una serie de cambios que hemos
ido viendo de una forma muy gradual este
esta pandemia lo que ha hecho acelerar
un poco y situarnos en un futuro que
vamos llegando de forma muy gradual pero
lo ha hecho en pocas semanas las
empresas ya vemos que se han adaptado al
teletrabajo ya vemos también que la
transformación digital se ha producido
una forma muy rápida también hemos
comprobado que
que todas estas tecnologías y demás ya
sea pedir pedir comida a domicilio el
uso de las plataformas en streaming para
escuchar música para ver series los
suscriptores de amazon se han aumentado
en el primer trimeste 15 millones de
personas es un número inmenso y como
decía mi compañera las compras online el
gran gigante amazon se ha disparado sus
ventas que eso también incide mucho en
el medio ambiente que esto es otro tema
que no es el lugar para tratarlo pero
todas estas cosas que hemos ido
adaptando son nuestros nuevos hábitos y
nuestras nuevas costumbres quizás haya
un periodo de pre ajuste cuando quizás
toda esta pandemia pase pero pero todo
esto ha venido para quedarse un poco y
vamos hacia hacia ello hablemos de
nuestra forma de relacionarnos anna
detengámonos un momento en este objeto
que tengo en mis manos en la mascarilla
y cómo ha revolucionado nuestro día a
día y lo que cambia relacionarnos con él
ya no vemos cuando sonreímos ya cuesta
gesticular cuesta ironizar nos cuesta
hemos tenido que cambiar todo este tipo
de lenguaje no verbal de los gestos que
tanto dicen
hemos perdido a la hora de socializarnos
hasta qué punto va a cambiar en el
futuro esa forma que teníamos de
socializarnos por ejemplo en cuanto al
contacto humano en dar besos en sonreír
nos esto es un esto es una revolución
brutal bueno es una revolución total y
además lo que me gustaría es un poco
incidir más que a la escala que estamos
hablando de la sociedad y demás en cómo
va a impactar en a nivel personal fíjate
que decías que es lo que hemos perdido y
es una reflexión que me una forma de
preguntar que me parece interesante
estamos pensando todo el tiempo a nivel
de la pandemia como a nivel de lo que
hemos perdido y lo que queremos
recuperar claro eso lleva también a
tener expectativas de volver a la
normalidad y en estas expectativas que
no se cumplen llega la frustración y
cuando llega la frustración lleva la
depresión de ahí también lo que tú
mencionabas antes del estado anímico y
de la fatiga pero fíjate que ya no se
trata simplemente de que estemos
perdiendo con la mascarilla sino que
quizá deberíamos cambiar la pregunta que
a nivel personal cuando nos pasa algo
traumático o algo señalable algo
significativo
evidentemente en nuestra vida cambia y
no
a volver a lo que pasó antes de ese
momento traumático o ese momento de
cambio pues algo que funciona así a
nivel individual también funciona a
nivel global el mundo va a cambiar el
mundo está cambiando pero no va no vamos
a volver a esa normalidad no vamos a
estar en otra posición y en esta en esta
posición
tenemos que buscar nuevas formas de
adaptarnos podemos demonizar las
mascarillas podemos pensar todo lo que
perdemos pero vamos vamos a ver también
hay otras formas de relacionarse también
tiene que ver todo hablamos del lenguaje
articular pero mi hija que yo que soy
soy de española goleó algo en la mano
entonces claro que tenemos otras formas
distintas de gesticular sólo tenemos que
aprender a hacer algo que no sabemos
escuchar y sabéis que es los alumnos que
no sabemos hacer que es escuchar no
sabemos escuchar lo que hacemos es ver
al otro pero no es pero tenemos la
mirada tenemos los gestos quizás se
trata de invertir vamos a dejar de
pensar en todo lo que hemos perdido
vamos a dejar de pensar oh dios mío qué
es lo que vamos a hacer porque la
normalidad se ha perdido se ha se ha
cambiado se ha transformado la forma de
relacionarnos y eso no es ni bueno ni
malo
somos nosotros en nuestra forma de
responder a la situación cómo lo hacemos
malo o bueno así que vamos a dejar de
demonizar la mascarilla muy interesante
antes de despedirme rápidamente una
ronda porque me quedan unos segundos
pensar bien un motivo positivo que nos
ayuda a combatir la fatiga emocional que
llevamos encima en este 2020 rápidamente
un motivo positivo para acabar con un
buen sabor de boca hoy el programa car
en respirar mejor medio ambiente un
motivo que nos deja este 2020 lo mismo
ya sabemos que las pandemias también
tienen que ver con la degradación de los
ecosistemas entonces ya sabemos qué
hacer tratar de vivir de otra forma
consumir de otra forma y también ya
sabemos que los fenómenos naturales se
conviertan en catástrofes cuando hay
vulnerabilidad y pobreza entonces luchar
contra la pobreza pues no me queda
tiempo para más ha sido un placer
compartir hoy está en primera plana
hablando de este año que ha cambiado
para para bien y para mal hay motivos
para todos nuestras vidas un placer
parental ya y anna ya todos ustedes
hasta la próxima semana quien en primera
plana gracias